y los países europeos se endurecen sus
medidas contra el cob y 19 el más
reciente fue españa donde el gobierno
anunció la implementación de un nuevo
estado de alarma para frenar el aumento
en el número de contagios y como es
sostenido
desde el inicio de la pandemia el estado
de alarma es la herramienta
constitucional para situaciones extremas
y la situación que vivimos es extrema
bajo este decreto habrá toque de queda
nocturno a nivel nacional y cada
comunidad autónoma podrá decidir si con
fina o no su territorio se prevé que la
medida se extienda hasta principios de
mayo
el fuerte crecimiento de la curva
epidemiológica en italia llevó al
gobierno a ordenar cierre de piscinas
gimnasios teatros y cines los bares y
restaurantes sólo podrán permanecer
abiertos hasta las 18 horas las medidas
buscan proteger tanto la salud como la
economía del país que un día fue el
epicentro de la pandemia significa que
es conjuraron significa evitar un
segundo cierre total como el que tuvimos
en primavera pero el país no se lo puede
permitir el país pero propio permiter
solo lo cambiamos no introducimos toques
de queda no nos gusta esa palabra hola
quien ahora me amo mar y william una
forte la comanda acciones pero deseamos
recomendar a todos que circulen sólo por
trabajo estudios o motivos necesarios
estudio disney es cita los casos de
coronavirus también se han disparado en
francia polonia y reino
pero los europeos buscan evitar a toda
costa un cierre total el continente
registra casi la mitad de los casos
diarios a nivel mundial y ahora se
convierte una vez más en el foco de la
pandemia